for nearly 20 years actress missy
peregrym has played strong female
characters on TV and in movies peregrym
has portrayed a rebellious gymnast and
stick it
a police officer in rookie blue and a
vampire hunter in van Helsing the
actresses latest role brings her to New
York yay to play special agent Maggie
Bell in the new CBS drama FBI in this
draw in this preview rather of tonight's
premiere episode agent Belle interrogate
tsubame suspect who's creepy Wilmer at
some point you and I are gonna sit down
and discuss exactly how you got involved
with ms-13 could jump to win what
choices you had everything but not
really he'll do that stop we have you on
camera so take a deep breath and let go
of any hope you have of talking your way
out of this and tell me who gave you
that bomb something tells me it's not
gonna end well for him missy peregrym
joins us at the table Missy we're glad
you're here but listen right when she
sat down people out there you told us
the best news your sisters in labor
right now is it her first baby no it's
not it's the third but I was there for
the second one and so I just keep
facetiming them yeah that's big news but
this is news to yes because here you are
the lead lead person on the FBI show it
is very very intense and you are a
badass on the show thank you you are
used to beatin people up taking names
and taking numbers so how do you deal
with the intensity of this role uh I'm
still trying to figure it out I would
say that maggie is a professional she's
done this for so long that there's
there's a confidence that she has she
knows how to deal with people and she's
not overly emotional with everything
that she's doing which is different than
rules have played before and that's kind
of saving me like this with not being
too overwhelmed with everything cuz you
said you have a passion for justice
which I do what does that mean it means
I like the truths and I want the right
thing to be done when something wrong
has happened and I want people to be
heard I really think it's it's valuable
and that their heart is seen so in all
of these episodes is what we're dealing
with how do you go to badass training
yeah there you got that you may not
already be one yourself
yeah I start with a bad attitude and I
younger
we go over then the pathway of life but
I mean on the evident what did the FBI
agents you work with tell you about how
to do how to be yes yeah well I was
pretty late to the project and so the
other cast got to do some more stuff but
we have Dan the man as I've nicknamed
him onset he's an ex-fbi agent and he
kind of takes us through how to do
things more interrogation stuff and how
you deal with people which I find
fascinating there's tactics with that
and how to get the truth and in terms of
you know pulling a weapon and and all
that other stuff what did you knew that
you didn't know before the tactics yeah
I'm not gonna tell you that right now
this is my power
we'll talk I like a show avoids politics
and said really focuses on the
incredible work that the New York FBI
does and they really do I mean people
the FBI is such an incredible
organization about how they protect
people I mean did you get a new
appreciation from from work that agents
do every day yeah I feel like I've
always had a lot of respect for law
enforcement because of that I think it's
a huge sacrifice to be going out and you
have no idea what's gonna happen to you
this in particular is different for me I
mean I didn't even want to watch the
news no fans for two years because it
was overwhelming for me all the stuff
that was happening I was so afraid of
this could happen to me and this could
happen to me taking this job scared me
so much because I knew that I was gonna
be going head into some of the most
traumatic and difficult situations I'm
really really proud to portray these
people who are on the ground who worked
tirelessly to sacrifice with their
families and their emotional well-being
honestly to face these things we're
we're glad you've moved to New York and
so is your dog and your dog is having a
little bit of an adjustment problem I
hear yes there's no grass to go who
didn't really know what to do with that
but now she just will take a weed and
crack then she goes yeah she's adjusted
but there's a menu of smells it's also
true walks take 400 hours yes welcome to
New York Thank You Missy paraben free
here and good luck to your sister later
today thank you FBI premieres tonight at
9:00 8:00 central right here on CBS